well the 2018 midterms are just seven
months away we can fully expect
Republicans to campaign on protecting
the border and keeping Americans safe
from illegal aliens as for the Democrats
well several Democratic candidates are
actually calling for the abolition of
ice don't believe me well Randy Bryce
who's challenging House Speaker Paul
Ryan in Wisconsin's first District
recently just told the truth and told
Newsweek quote I think that ice should
be abolished and Congress should explore
which existing agency could best house
Immigration and Customs Enforcement end
quote
well joining me now for reaction is
David Ward a former ice agent who also
worked on the border David thank you for
your time so Democrats are clinging to
the idea that it get rid of ice is gonna
get rid of this problem for us what do
you say to that you know we live in a
great country where people as vacuous as
Bryce can run for a congressional seat
and make a statement like he did to
abolish ice I mean who does he expect to
work in the interior of the United
States to go after criminal aliens that
have eluded other police departments now
one thing a baby no I mean is this not
indicative of a viewpoint that says we
want a borderless world we law and order
does not matter to us but the Democrats
will not be happy until immigration is
completely abolished there's no border
patrol there's no border there's no wall
there's no ice there's no nothing and
people come and go as they wish in the
United States let me tell you something
about this mr. Bryce if you're listening
you know I see agents arrested over
38,000 criminal aliens you made a
statement that were out there arresting
children and the families and stuff let
me tell you something
ice is going out specifically for
particular targets that are criminal
aliens that have warrants for arrests
that are fugitives from justice that
came to the United States after a
reentry after deportation that's who's
being targeted and over 38,000 have been
arrested did you also know that over
2,200 pounds of fentanyl have been of
course seized by ice yeah I mean it's a
drug problem the gang problem the
violence program are all very very real
but it's not just this one congressional
candidate in Wisconsin you've got a
congressional scanner in Indiana you've
got one in New York
I mean this seems to be in the
bloodstream of the Democratic Party the
progressive talking points that are
doing this they don't want immigration
enforcement they want this entire
country to be a sanctuary for the
world's problems we can't do it our
citizens are in danger look at what
happened on 9/11 it was immigrants that
did that they brought down the towers
and since then illegal aliens and
foreign nationals have been killing US
citizens since that time even before
then of course we talk a lot a lot about
the border and rightfully so because
that's where so much of our problem
emanates from but as far as ice is
concerned these are visa overstays as
well these are the people a lot of
people that come here legally and they
decide not to go back and ultimately
without a cent of your illegal alien
population or example they violate our
visas that come in to the United States
the visa waiver program is another big
problem that we should take a real close
look at and abolish that immigration is
the Achilles heel of this country if we
don't control if we don't control our
borders don't go after the illegally
onsets are within this country we're
gonna have a real serious problem within
a very short period of time so they say
well Isis only been around for 15 years
it's it's a short term agency I mean
this is the talking points at the left
are abolish it because it's something
new explain to us about the history
there okay since 1933 immigration has
been in effect we've had special agents
from 1933 to 2003 enforcing immigration
law the Department of Homeland Security
was created because of 9/11 through the
9/11 Commission and ice became
immigration special agents that's the
only different was the name they all go
through the same school they all enforce
Title 8 and I'd like to know who this
guy thinks is going to enforce Title II
all of our Regents go through an Academy
to learn how to enforce it well of
course I mean I guess he's counting on
self deportation ultimately I mean
really I mean they they Mock the idea
until their entire premise is built on
it but you say so let me deliberate
operation and focus target targets is
what ice is about and the boogeyman is
they make it look like they're running
around rounding people up look that we
only have 20,000 at most
I see agents throughout the entire
United States that's half the size of
the New York City Police Department but
we have 11 million people that we might
be looking for
it's a small number so we have to
concentrate on the most effective use of
our manpower one that's going after the
criminal aliens that are causing a harm
in these neighborhoods make sense David
thank you for your time and for your
service to this country